- [Instructor] What we see here is known
as a trophic pyramid,
and the word trophic,
in a biology context, is
referring to food relationships.
So one way to think about this,
it tells us who is eating whom,
and who is producing energy,
and then who is able to
leverage that energy.
So the base of a trophic pyramid,
you have your primary
producers, primary producers.
These are often known as autotrophs,
because they're able to
take energy from the sun,
so sun's energy, and nutrients
that are available to them,
and store some of that energy as biomass.
And biomass is just a fancy
word for the actual substance
of the organism that is
inherently storing energy.
When someone tells you that that piece
of food has a certain number of calories,
that's because there's
energy stored in it.
Calories are a unit of energy.
And so, let's just say, if you
were to take a square meter,
if you were to average on
a per square meter basis,
these primary producers
in this environment,
let's say they're able to
store 20,000 kilocalories
per square meter per year.
What's interesting
about a trophic pyramid,
it helps describe, well, okay,
that energy's stored as
biomass, what happens then?
Well, then you could go to the next level,
and you could view these as your primary
or first-level consumers.
So first-level, well, I
could call them level one
or primary consumers,
these are the organisms
that would eat the primary producers.
But not all of that energy gets restored
as biomass in these organisms.
In fact, there is a lot of loss.
On average, when we look at ecosystems,
it tends to be only about 10% makes it
from one level of our
trophic pyramid to the next.
So at this level, on a per,
on average, per square meter,
instead of 20,000
kilocalories being stored
as biomass per year, you'd
only have 10% of that.
So it might only be 2,000.
2,000 kilocalories per
square meter per year.
So notice, you have that drop-off.
And then you could go to
the next level after that,
you could view these as
the secondary consumers.
These are the folks who might
eat the primary consumers,
the first-level consumers.
You get another 10%
drop-off, so you would,
or I should say, a 90% drop-off,
only 10% gets transferred.
So about 200, 200 kilocalories
per square meter per year.
And it keeps happening, the
folks who eat those folks,
well then, you've dropped off
at this level right over here.
You could call these the
third-level consumers,
or sometimes viewed as tertiary consumers.
This would be about 20 kilocalories
per square meter per year.
And this doesn't mean that
every square meter will have
exactly 20 kilocalories of biomass of,
let's say in this example, snake.
It just means that if you
were to look at the biomass
of snakes, and you were to average them
across this ecosystem, the surface area,
then you might average
about 20 kilocalories
per square meter per year.
And then you get to the
top of this pyramid.
And this, you could view as
your level four consumer.
You could view this as,
since they're at the top of the pyramid,
this is sometimes known
as the apex predator.
But every stage here, you only are able
to transfer 10% of the biomass.
So here, you have two kilocalories
per square meter per year.
And what's useful about
this, it helps us understand
what an ecosystem can support.
It can support a lot of biomass
of our primary producers,
but it can support very little biomass
of our apex predators, and that's why,
if you were to go into the forest,
you would see very few apex predators.
If you were to look at the apex predators
and you were to think about their biomass
in terms of kilocalories, and
spread it over their region
where they have to find
food, it would be much lower
than the average biomass
per square meter of,
say, the grass and the trees.
Now, an interesting thing is, well,
where is a lot of that
energy getting lost to?
Well, in a lot of cases, these
organisms are moving around.
They have to do things,
they have processes
in their own body, and those
things all generate heat.
So even plants, even plants generate heat.
So all of these characters
are, there's some energy
that's being released as heat.
Also, when these players die,
they are decomposed by other organisms.
So all this biomass, it's
either just going to die,
or it's going to get eaten,
but even when it gets eaten,
all of the energy doesn't get transferred.
Some of it stays in the
undigested material,
which we refer to as poop, and so,
those dead bodies, that
dead biomass, or this poop
that still contains energy,
is going to be fed on
by what we call decomposers, decomposers.
And they really break
things down into nutrients,
which then can be consumed
by the primary producers
as they utilize the sun's energy
and keep the cycle going after that.
Now, one interesting
thing to think about is,
what if there are
changes to the ecosystem?
What if, for example, a
nearby volcano erupts?
And that volcano, let me draw that,
it's a fun thing to draw,
that volcano erupts and
ash goes into the sky,
and all year it's just really gray.
What do you think would happen?
Well, the sun's energy that's
able to hit the surface
of the earth in this area
would go down by a good bit.
And so, if that went down by a good bit,
then the primary producers
might not be able
to store 20,000 kilocalories
per square meter per year.
It might go down to 2,000 kilocalories
per square meter per
year, and in which case,
you'd drop to a zero off of all of these.
So instead of 20,000,
it might go to 2,000.
Instead of 2,000, this would be 200.
Instead of 200, this would be 20.
Instead of 20, this would be two.
Instead of two, this would 0.2.
And so, something like
the loss of light energy,
even though this apex predator doesn't
directly photosynthesize, a
lot fewer of them are going
to be able to be supported
in that ecosystem
if you have a lot less
energy stored at biomass,
at the primary production
level, because there's just less
of sun's energy to be able
to be stored as biomass.
There could be other things
that happen in the ecosystem.
Let's say that some
pesticides get introduced,
and some of these level one
consumers start dying out.
Well then, you might have less
of the transfer of biomass
from the primary producer level
to the primary consumer
level, which, once again,
might affect these other
levels of the trophic pyramid.
So this is an interesting
thing to think about.
Ecosystems are these really complex,
intertwined things, and one impact
at one area could have
far-reaching consequences
throughout the entire ecosystem.
It's also interesting to think
of ecosystems as energy transfer.
Energy's coming from the
sun, and it's being cycled
through this ecosystem,
through this pyramid.
Some of it gets stored as
biomass and gets transferred
to other forms of biomass, but
a lot of it gets lost as heat
as these organisms' cells go
through different processes.
The organisms are running around,
living their life, doing whatever.